une coupure ou une égratignure à chaque
bobo un pansement qui protège peut être
utile chaque année l'entreprise urgo
lance une trentaine de nouveautés visant
le grand public sur le marché de la
cicatrisation
hugo est aujourd'hui le champion
français mais aussi le numéro deux en
europe commence ici libre à chenôve près
de dijon un jeune pharmacien rachète
d'abord une droguerie en faillite
puis les laboratoires pharmaceutiques
fournier en 1958 il lance la marque eu
recours
son fils hervé le loose aujourd'hui
président du groupe urgo donc nous
raconte aujourd'hui pendant la guerre
cette droguerie fabriquait déjà des
pansements de manière assez archaïque
mais je j'ai le souvenir d'une grande
table on this on tendait des draps 1 au
pinceau on passait la colle à l'oxydé de
zinc et les ouvriers repliait de la gaze
et au ciseau on coupait mettez un papier
gaufré et on mettait en boîte il y adeux
lieu dans l'ère ali il y à de l'air
dolgo 1978 le premier pansement à trous
une révolution à l'époque sont morts la
première diversification cr-v le loup ce
qu'il amorce en 1987 il crée juvamine
première marque de vitamines en grande
surface puis il rachète mercurochrome
marie rose ou encore humex au décès de
son père il regroupe les entreprises
aujourd'hui
hurbault fabrique plus de 1200 produits
etc briac luz le fils aîné qui dirige la
filiale santé grand public
énormément de besoins qui sont
aujourd'hui pas couverts et c'est là où
nous on joue notre rôle c'est à dire
qu'on cherche à trouver des solutions
sur les pratiques de santé qui
aujourd'hui sont pas encore complètement
développé une croissance de 7% par an
plus de 3200 salariés dont 1200 en
france une fierté pour ce patron qui a
bâti une multinationale de la santé
le produisons en france 80% de ce que
nous vendons des produits ici en région
dijonnaise et dans les autres usines
françaises principalement du goût et de
nos expéditions pour la france et pour
le monde se passe ici pour faire face
aux géants du marché comme boiron
johnson and johnson ou encore sanofi le
groupe investit chaque année 25 millions
d'euros dans la recherche
exemple avec ce pansement qui facilite
la cicatrisation des diabétiques pour
arriver à ça c'est 18 ans de recherches
et d'amélioration continue des produits
et le contenu en soixante ans plus tard
l'histoire se poursuit ici à paris avec
le petit fils du fondateur qui à son
tour explore avec son équipe de
nouvelles technologies au service de la
santé
on est la deuxième génération nous
puisque chaque génération continue créer
d'inventer de nouvelles entreprises
et c'est ça je pense que le rêve
continue de perpétuer urgo night ce
casque d'entraînement cérébral pour
réapprendre à son cerveau à dormir
sortira sur le marché en 2020